Hey there, Will Arnett here from SmartList. It's the podcast where Jason Bateman, Sean Hayes, and I interview somebody. Two of us don't know who that person is because one of us has brought on a surprise guest. That's the whole conceit. I wish I could describe it better, but I'm not that smart. So it's SmartList, and it's starting now. Will, with the little tiny goatee we have going on, you look a little like Gomez from the Adams family.
大家好，我是SmartLess的威尔·阿奈特。在这个播客里，杰森·贝特曼、肖恩·海耶斯和我每期会采访一位嘉宾。我们其中两人事先不知道嘉宾是谁，因为另外一人会带来一位惊喜嘉宾。这就是节目的全部构思。我真希望我能把它描述得更好，但我没那么聪明。所以这就是SmartLess，现在开始。威尔，你留着那撮小山羊胡，看起来有点像《亚当斯一家》里的戈麦斯。
Thank you. You're welcome. I can't tell if that's... I take everything as a compliment. It's a great way to go through life. You just constantly go, thank you. Can you guys tell that I've got a little bit of a goatee going here? I've got about eight weeks of growth, and you can barely see it.
谢谢。不客气。我看不出那是……我把一切都当作赞美。这是度过人生的一种好方法。你只需要不断地说，谢谢。你们能看出我留了一点山羊胡吗？我已经留了大约八周了，但几乎看不出来。
That's not true. You can get a nice little beard going sometimes. It's a little gengy. Did you sew some of the mustache beard stuff from the hair on your head? Did you glue it together, like make a... We got to get Forte on here one time, because Forte, apparently when he was a writer on that 70s show, we were working on Brother Solomon in the... Will Forte was a writer on that 70s show?
那不是真的。你有时也能留出不错的胡子。有点稀疏。你是从头上剪下一些头发粘在胡子上的吗？你是把它粘在一起，就像做了一个……我们得找个机会把福特请来，因为福特，显然当他在《70年代秀》当编剧时，我们正在制作《所罗门兄弟》……威尔·福特是《70年代秀》的编剧？
Yeah, yeah, sure. And on the letterman. I didn't know that. Yeah, and he goes... And she goes, oh, I remember Will. He made her give him one of those Styrofoam heads that you have for... You put a wig on to help it keep its shape. I have hundreds of them, because for all my various ways.
对，对，当然。还有《大卫深夜秀》。我不知道。对，她说……她说，哦，我记得威尔。他让她给了他一个那种用来展示假发的泡沫人头。我有几百个，因为我有很多种用途。
And Forte, over the course of a year, would get his hair cut by her, and he saved his clippings, and he put hair on the Styrofoam thing, and then he made a face. And then for facial hair, he used his hair short and curly, and then he gave it to John Solomon as a president at the end of the year as a representation of himself. A pubic hair wig. The wig was real hair, and it was so gross, and that's just Forte. We got to get him on here. Speaking of hair, I want you to know that I've showered, I've shampooed, and I've conditioned
福特在一年里，会让她帮他剪头发，他把剪下来的头发存起来，粘在泡沫人头上，然后做了一个脸。至于胡子，他用了自己又短又卷的头发，然后在年底把它作为礼物送给约翰·所罗门，作为他自己的化身。一个阴毛假发。那个假发是真头发，太恶心了，这就是福特。我们得把他请来。说到头发，我想让你知道，为了今天的嘉宾，我洗了澡，洗了头，还用了护发素。
my hair for today's guest. It looks good. Wow. I've been around today at all. That's incredible. This is a top shelf guest. You both might want to just kind of maybe take a break and watch a friend's rerun or something like that.
我的头发。看起来不错。哇。我今天一直在忙。太不可思议了。这是一位顶级嘉宾。你们俩可能想休息一下，去看个老友记重播什么的。
Will, I know you're partial to Canadian sports. Sure. Sean, I know that you're not allergic to sports, but it's not upfront on your... You don't have any sort of like sports screensavers or anything like that. Not this anymore. This gentleman has played 12 seasons in the major leagues, debuted in 2008. He's an eight-time All-Star. He's a three-time National League Cy Young Award winner.
威尔，我知道你偏爱加拿大体育。当然。肖恩，我知道你不排斥体育，但它不是你的首选……你没有任何像体育类的屏保之类的东西。现在没有了。这位先生在大联盟打了12个赛季，2008年首次亮相。他八次入选全明星。他三次获得国家联盟赛扬奖。
He's a 2014 National League Most Valuable Player. His 2.4 career earned run average, and 1.01 walks per hits, per innings pitched is whip. That's the lowest among starters in the live ball era. Kevin Costner. We have Mr. Clayton Kershaw with us today. No way. Okay. Well, this guy I've heard of.
他是2014年国家联盟最有价值球员。他职业生涯2.4的防御率，以及每局被上垒率（WHIP）1.01。这是活球时代先发投手中的最低纪录。凯文·科斯特纳。我们今天请到了克莱顿·克肖先生。不会吧。好吧。这个家伙我听说过。
Look at that. Look at that. That's a beard. That is a beard. Thank you. It's really not good though, but yeah. Hi, pal. Very nice of you to say yes to this.
看看那个。看看那个。那才是胡子。那确实是胡子。谢谢。虽然真的不怎么样，但确实是。嗨，伙计。你能答应来这里真是太好了。
Thanks for having me, guys. I'm excited. It was fun to listen to y'all banter. Yeah. Do you guys know each other? Slightly. I went to the ping pong tournament a couple of years. He has a ping pong tournament on the field at Dodger Stadium, which is pretty awesome.
谢谢你们邀请我，伙计们。我很兴奋。听你们闲聊很有趣。对。你们认识吗？稍微认识。我几年前去过乒乓球锦标赛。他在道奇体育场球场上举办乒乓球锦标赛，这非常棒。
How many years have you guys done that? Man, we've done it for, yeah, probably six or seven years now. It's pretty fun. This year, obviously, I had to get canceled, but it is a good time, and I mean, Jason, you come to quite a few games. I mean, you're there quite a bit. Well, I used to go to every game. I've dragged Will do a couple.
你们举办多少年了？伙计，我们大概做了六七年了。挺有趣的。今年，显然，不得不取消了，但那是一段美好的时光，我是说，杰森，你参加过不少比赛。我是说，你经常去。嗯，我以前每场比赛都去。我拖着威尔去过几次。
I do explain that, you know, stop waiting for the horn and the park, the period breaks. But I used to go to every game, then I got a wife and a couple of children and on a job. And so now I just come to 20 games a year or something like that, but I watch every single game. Wow. You only go to 20 now? Ish. Do you still have that dumb license plate frame that you like?
我确实解释过，你知道，别等着看记分牌和局间休息。但我以前每场比赛都去，后来我有了妻子和几个孩子，还有一份工作。所以现在我一年只去20场左右，但我会看每一场比赛。哇。你现在只去20场了？差不多吧。你还有那个你喜欢的愚蠢的车牌框吗？
No, I never got a license plate frame. Follow me to Dodger Blue. Don't have dare you. Not in front of Clayton. Do you remember you had that? How many games does your wife, Ellen, watch? Does she watch every game? Yeah, she, so they have childcare at Dodger Stadium.
不，我从来没买过车牌框。别跟着我到道奇蓝。你敢。别在克莱顿面前提。你还记得你有那个吗？你妻子艾伦看多少场比赛？她每场都看吗？对，他们，他们在道奇体育场有托儿服务。
So that's kind of like a break almost for the game, you know, she can, I don't know if she actually watches the game, but she goes. She goes to every home game? Just about. Yeah. Just about. Even when you're not pitching. Yeah.
所以这几乎就像是比赛的休息时间，你知道，她可以，我不知道她是否真的在看比赛，但她去了。她每场主场比赛都去吗？差不多。对。差不多。即使你不投球的时候也是？对。
Well, it's not like she's going to watch the game, but she's there with the other wives and they hang out, you know, maybe have a glass of wine or something. It's kind of like, you know, just hanging out. It's like Amanda and Ozark. Amanda's not going to watch every episode, but she will drink when she's playing with the kids. It's good to know that Ellen's up to the same thing. For sure.
嗯，她也不是非要看比赛，但她和其他球员的妻子在一起，她们会聚在一起，你知道，也许喝杯红酒什么的。这就像，你知道，只是聚在一起。就像《黑钱胜地》里的阿曼达。阿曼达不会看每一集，但她会在和孩子们玩的时候喝酒。很高兴知道艾伦也在做同样的事。当然。
Wait. So Clayton, so a couple of things. First of all, how many kids you got? A couple? I have three now. Yeah. Wow. I have three.
等等。所以克莱顿，有几件事。首先，你有几个孩子？几个？我现在有三个了。对。哇。我有三个。
Yeah. Same. Yeah. We just had, Cooper's our youngest now. He's, he just got to be six months. So we're, we're in the trenches for sure right now. Wow. Dude, I'm right behind you.
对。一样。对。我们刚有了，库珀是我们最小的孩子。他，他才六个月大。所以我们现在确实处于水深火热之中。哇。伙计，我紧随其后。
We're at, we're at about. You're late. You're, you're, you're at like five now. I have four. I have three in his, in his steps. Oh, always we're talking about kids, not nannies. Oh, I have four nannies. Yeah. Yeah. We're on floor. Yeah. We're on full man coverage over here.
我们大概在。你晚了。你，你，你现在大概在五个左右。我有四个。我有三个在他，在他之后。哦，我们一直在谈论孩子，不是保姆。哦，我有四个保姆。对。对。我们这边是全员防守。
Wait. So you've got three kids. You're right in that. You're right in the zone with their little and it requires a lot of energy. Well, it's zone defense, right? At three, two, you guys were man to man and it was manageable. How old are the other ones? Yeah. So Callie's our oldest. She's a five and a half and then Charlie's three and a half. So girl, boy, boy, like five, three and six months. And yeah, zone defense, it, it's different.
等等。所以你有三个孩子。你正处于那个阶段，他们还小，需要很多精力。嗯，是区域防守，对吧？三个，两个，你们是人盯人，还能应付。其他的多大了？对。卡莉是我们最大的。她五岁半，然后查理三岁半。所以女孩，男孩，男孩，五岁，三岁和六个月。对，区域防守，这，这不一样。
You know, yeah. Please tell me you had some help. You're not those parents that can do it all on your own and you don't need any help. I need help. I don't know if Ellen needs help. I need help, but Ellen, I think Ellen can handle it, but with the season and stuff, we do have somebody help us. So it's good. And how, what, when you travel away, like I, I go away when we do Ozark, but I'm back every weekend, you guys are gone for two weeks at a time often. Is that, it's going to be tough to get an honest answer out of you here. But I mean, it's, there, there's a, there's
你知道，对。请告诉我你有一些帮手。你不是那种可以独自完成所有事情，不需要任何帮助的父母。我需要帮助。我不知道艾伦是否需要帮助。我需要帮助，但艾伦，我想艾伦能应付，但随着赛季什么的，我们确实有人帮忙。所以这很好。当你出差时，比如我，我拍《黑钱胜地》时会离开，但我每个周末都会回来，你们经常一次离开两周。这，要从你这里得到一个诚实的回答会很难。但我是说，那，那两周里有几天是平静而愉快的。是的，你可以承认这个问题。我不知道我是否被允许承认这一点。杰森想要为他自己的感受寻求一些验证。承认有48小时的，至少，那，那离开洛杉矶的飞机航程怎么样？我会这么说。我认为你终于可以睡觉，不用在孩子醒来时被吵醒的第一天，是一件美妙的事情。那确实很棒。但我确实发现自己，你在去球场之前一直都很忙。你只是，你只是不断地做事情，无论是跳蹦床，还是，你知道，无论是什么，你只是在忙，但然后，你看不到他们，你在路上的酒店里。你会想，我该做什么？我不知道。我能看的《黑钱胜地》也就那么多了。你知道，就像，看完之后我就没事做了。对。对。因为那会让你直接回去睡觉，然后你会错过大巴。现在我必须告诉你，当这些人带一个体育界的人来时，我被你是世界上最著名的投手这一事实所吸引。对。对。
a couple of days of those two weeks where it is peaceful and enjoyable. Yes, you can admit to question. I don't know if I'm allowed to admit to that. Jason wants some validation for his own feelings. Admit to 48 hours of like, at least how about, how about the plane ride out of Los Angeles? I will say this. I think the first day that you get to like sleep and not wake up when the kid wakes you up is, is a glorious thing. And that is, that is awesome. But then I do find myself like, you're just so busy until you go to the field. You just like, you're
别，别，你不需要回答那个。我不知道。对。不，你是。我被这种天赋所吸引。我是说，我从小就打棒球、篮球、橄榄球之类的。所以我不是那种对这一切一无所知的书呆子。我实际上对你的历史和成功感到非常着迷和印象深刻。我是说，没有人，地球上没有人能触及你。这太疯狂了。嗯，你们也是。对。演戏也是一个完全不同的层面。这是我，我喜欢这类故事。所以克莱顿，你和马修·斯塔福德从高中就认识了。我确实喜欢这个。对。对。但肖恩知道马修是谁吗？马修·斯塔福德是底特律雄狮队的四分卫。他还在，他还在雄狮队吗？对。他还在雄狮队。他仍然拿着大合同之一，如果你看的话，过去10年里，没有人比马特·斯塔福德投球赚的钱更多。是真的吗？得了吧。
just doing stuff constantly, whether it jump on the trampoline or, you know, whatever it is, and you're just going, but then like, you don't see him and you're in the road at a hotel. You're like, what, what am I supposed to do? I have no idea. There's only so much Ozark I can watch. You know, it's like, I'm done after that. Yeah. Yeah. Cause it'll put you right back to bed and then you'll miss the bus. Now I have to tell you, when one of these guys brings a sports person on, I'm fascinated by the fact that you are, you're like the most famous pitcher in the world. Yeah. Yeah.
是的。马修，马修。我知道我这么说是为了让他生气，然后他就会想来，然后我们就可以请他来了，但等等，等等，他会纠正你吗？如果你介绍他是马特，他会说马修吗？所以我认为，我认为发生的事情是，当他出名时，他们就开始叫他马特，但他从来不是马特。他一直都是马修。我不知道。我不知道，我不再经常和他说话了，但我不知道他是否是故意改的，但对我来说，他一直，他是马修，但他是一位出色的四分卫。他也是一位出色的运动员。所以带我们了解一下你和马修·斯塔福德是怎么认识的。但克莱顿是他的中锋，肖恩。克莱顿给他发球。哦，哇。我没说错吧，克莱顿？对。我是说，你直接跳过了整个故事，但那基本上，那是结局。所以对，我们不必讲了。所以是怎么发生的？你和马修·斯塔福德是怎么认识的？我们一起长大。我是说，我们一起长大，从我们开始，比如，我们一起踢足球。
Don't, don't you don't need to answer that. I don't know. Yeah. No, you are. And I'm fascinated by the talent. I mean, I grew up playing baseball and basketball and football and all that stuff. So I, I'm not like a dork loser about all of it. I'm actually fascinated by and so impressed with your history and your success. I mean, it's, there's nobody, there's nobody on earth that can touch you. It's crazy. Well, likewise with you guys. Yeah. Just acting is a whole different level too. Here's the thing that I've, I'm, I love these kinds of stories. So Clayton, you and Matthew
在哪里？什么地方？达拉斯。德克萨斯州的达拉斯。对，我是说，我们，我们玩所有的运动。马修打棒球、篮球、橄榄球，他在棒球方面比我在橄榄球方面强多了。对，高中时我们是好哥们。然后，你知道，他，他去了佐治亚大学打橄榄球。对，但他很棒。他显然是个很棒的人。对。
Stafford have known each other since high school. I do love this. Yeah. Right. Yeah. Does Sean know who Matthew is though? Matthew Stafford is a quarterback for the Detroit Lions. Is he still, is he still with the Lions? Yeah. He's still with the Lions. He's still under one of the big, if you look, nobody has earned more money in the last 10 years, throwing a football than Matt Stafford. Is that true? Come on.
但在他上大学之前，因为你没有，你，你高中毕业后直接进入了棒球界。对。嗯，我甚至没从高中毕业。所以你比我领先。对。我大学退学了。所以在这个房间里你没问题。你做了一个决定。我还在继续。你做了一个决定，停止打橄榄球，100%的时间投棒球。
Yes. Matthew, Matthew. I know I'm saying that to make him so he'll get mad and then want to come on and then we can have him on, but wait, wait, does he correct you? If you introduce him as Matt, does he say Matthew? So I think, I think what happened was when he became famous, they just started calling him Matt, but he's never been a Matt. He's always been Matthew. I don't know. I don't, I don't talk to him regularly anymore that often, but I don't know if he changed it on purpose, but to me, he's always, He's Matthew, but he's an incredible quarterback. He's an incredible athlete as well. So walk
对。那是高中一年级。我只是，我橄榄球打得不太好。我，从来都不是。然后，你知道，你说了，我是中锋。我在打进攻线。我只是被打得很惨，而且那不是，那不是，那不好玩。所以我，我喜欢橄榄球。我喜欢看橄榄球，但我跑得不够快，做不了什么有趣的事。所以他们把我放在线上，我有点胖，那是我的位置。所以，但对，在那之后我就开始只打棒球了。因为打棒球可以是个胖子。你可以看起来像个垒球运动员，而且打得还不错。你可以，你会想看看红袜队。他们只是一群垒球运动员。他们只是不断地击球，击球，击球。棒球里确实有一些有趣的体型。那是给你的。这比杰森说的要外交得多。对。我们得找个马克斯·芒西，一个扎实的家伙。嘿，他是个深藏不露的运动员。他真的是。他甚至能跳得很高，你不会觉得。他比你快，对吧？他真的很快。就像真的，是我们队里跑得最快的人之一。太疯狂了。他太棒了。喜欢那个家伙。所以你，你玩各种不同的运动，我相信你都做得很好。然后你现在三十多岁了？
us through a little bit how you and Matthew Stafford know each other. But Clayton was his center, Sean. Clayton snapped him the ball. Oh wow. Do I have that right Clayton? Yeah. I mean, you just skipped ahead like the whole story, but that's basically, that's the end of it. So yeah, we don't have to tell it. So how did it happen? How did you and Matthew Stafford know each other? We grew up together. I mean, we grew up together starting like, we played like, we played soccer
32岁。一样。所以，所以你，你，嗯，所以你玩所有这些不同的运动。那个时刻是什么？所以你说你停止打橄榄球了。所以你是高中一年级。我总是对，比如，投棒球太难了。嗯，任何人都可以扔球，但要投棒球，当你真正开始控制投球时，当你执行你想做的事情时，无论是无论是什么，无论是曲球还是什么，那个你开始执行，你不仅仅是在扔，有人看到它并说，嘿孩子，对，就像，那个年龄是多少？就像，你是在后院第一次做那个吗？你是在为高中打球还是伙计，我不知道。我只是总是喜欢棒球。我总是，我总是玩，你知道，我六七岁时就开始玩了，嗯，大概10或11岁时开始投球。我总是，我总是还可以，你知道，然后高中三年级到了，我真的长大了。我变得大多了，嗯，我开始投得快多了，我就想，伙计，我可能可以去大学做这个。然后四年级，果然，我开始投得更快一点，投得更好一点。我被道奇队选中了。所以这只是，它发生得太快了，但它，对，它，它真的很酷。
together. Where? What part? Dallas. Dallas in Texas. And yeah, I mean, we, we played all the sports. Matthew played baseball, basketball, football, and he was way better at baseball than I ever was at football. And yeah, good buddies all through high school. And then, you know, he, you know, he went to Georgia to play football there. And yeah, but he's great. He's a great guy, obviously. Yeah.
然后那个不去德州农工大学，直接进入小联盟的决定，那是一个冒险的决定，因为，如果小联盟不成功怎么办？现在，你有没有想过，好吧，我可以随时，我只是延期入学，我可以以后再去德州农工大学。那是怎么运作的？不，它只是，我是说，只是经济上，他们付钱让我去打棒球。所以我加入了。对。但如果它不成功，比如如果很多人去了小联盟却从未进入大联盟，嗯，你会回大学吗？
But before he went to college, since you did not, you, you came right out of high school into baseball. Yeah. Well, I didn't even graduate high school. So you're ahead of me. Yeah. I dropped out of college. So you're fine in this room. You made a decision. I'm still going. You made a decision to stop playing football and throw the baseball 100% of the time.
对。其中一些合同，谢天谢地，球队确实会做，他们，他们，他们预留了一点钱让你去上大学。比如如果你打了一定年限却没有成功，他们，他们预留了一点钱让你去上大学。所以我认为这很棒。而且他们仍然这样做，这太棒了。哇。那很酷。你觉得你会学什么？伙计，学校不是，嗯，农工大学，所以你打算，你打算做某种农业，收获，主要是农业和机械。嗯，不，我当时的女朋友，现在是妻子，去了农工大学。所以她承诺去农工大学。所以我当时想，哦，我会，我会跟上。天哪，你说现在是妻子。对。和现在的妻子。对，同一个。所以她，她去了农工大学。她在那里学什么，传播学。她是传播学专业的。对。她是一位非常好的公众演讲者。那太棒了。现在，在我们离开你生活的橄榄球部分之前，你是道奇队里那些痴迷于梦幻橄榄球的人之一吗，你们进行大选秀和所有那些东西？
Yeah. That was freshman year high school. I just, I wasn't very good at football. I was, was never. And then, you know, you said it, I was the center. I was playing offensive line. I was just getting beat up and just wasn't, it wasn't, it wasn't fun. So I, I love football. I love watching football, but I wasn't fast enough to do anything fun. So they put me on the line and I was a little chunky and that was my spot. So, but yeah, I started just playing baseball after that. Cause you can be a heavy dude playing, playing baseball. You can look like a softball player and be pretty good at it. You can, you'll want to look at the Red Sox. They're just
谢谢你提起这件事。因为你得开始准备，对吧？对。我们是梦幻橄榄球的卫冕冠军。我的搭档，罗斯·斯特里普林是我的梦幻搭档。不错。嗯，所以是卫冕冠军。那是，现在有奖杯吗？我们有一个奖杯，我有一个基地。我是我的棒球梦幻联盟的专员，我们，我们有一个奖杯。我们把它运到全国各地给获胜者。谢谢。我们确实有一个奖杯。我们有。
a bunch of softball players. They just rake and rake and rake. There's some interesting body types in baseball for sure. And that's for you. It's much more diplomatic than what Jason was saying. Yeah. We got to go a max Muncie, a guy solid. Hey, he's a sneaky athlete. He really is. He can like, he can jump out of the gym too, which you would not. He's faster than you, right? He's really fast. Like seriously, one of the faster guys on our team. It's crazy. He's so good. Love that guy. So you're, you're playing all the different sports and I'm sure you're doing well at all of them. And then are you in your thirties now?
你们确实有一个奖杯？对。谁睡着了？我睡着了，因为杰森谈论作为他联盟的专员，他是一个多重专员。你还在做，你还在，你是专员吗？不，我把它减到一个了。我现在有工作了。等等，你是认真的吗？杰森，你是球队的专员？没错。哦，对。对。对。没错。而且我不接受任何废话。好吧。我把奥伯曼踢出了联盟，因为他对我喜欢加入的一些规则说了太多废话。你们和奥伯曼吵过多少次架？我们也要把他请来。这样他就可以，比如讲讲他的那一面，但你和基思·奥伯曼在梦幻棒球上吵过很多次架。争论意味着有赢家和输家。你不能，没有，当你和他争论时没有竞争。你只是，你刚开始。你就会输。所以最好的办法就是把他踢出联盟，而且他总是赢。
32. Same. So, so you're, you're, um, so you're playing all these different sports. What is the moment? So you said you stopped playing football. So you're a freshman in high school. I'm always interested by like, it's so hard to pitch a baseball. Well, anybody can throw a ball, but to pitch a baseball, when you actually start having control over pitches, when you're executing the thing that you want to do, whether it's whatever it is, whether it's a curveball or whatever, what is that moment where you start executing where you're pitching, you're not just throwing and somebody sees it and says, Hey kid, yeah, like, what is that age though? Like, are you in your backyard when you first do that? Are you playing
我告诉过你，当，当我以前在同一个联盟玩梦幻橄榄球，而基思也在时，我试着做几次，他最近向某人声称我不会和他交易。我说，不，不，不，我试着让他交易，然后他根本不回答我。我就想，好吧，因为它们对你可能是有利可图的。嗯，对。你以为我为什么要进行交易？所以克莱顿，我有一个问题。你是左撇子，对吧？
for high school or man, I don't know. I just always love baseball. I was always, I was always playing, you know, I started playing when I was six or seven and, um, started pitching probably when I was 10 or 11. And I was always, I was always okay, you know, and then junior year high school hit and I really grew. I got a lot bigger and, um, I started throwing a lot harder and I was like, man, I might get to go to college to do this. And then senior year, sure enough, I started throwing a little bit harder and pitching a little bit better. And I got to get drafted by the Dodgers. So it was just, uh, it happened so fast, but it was, yeah, it was, it was really cool.
我是左撇子。是的。那是什么感觉？不，我在开玩笑。嗯，告诉我关于，比如，用叉子难吗？哇。因为你知道，大多数人是右撇子。所以我，嗯，不，嗯，但回到威尔说的，还有杰森说的一点，比如如果你去上学，一定有其他事情你可能至少会尝试，或者其他兴趣，或者，你知道，你的梦想是什么，除了那个？好吧，我们能回到左撇子的问题吗？因为这对我来说很重要。所以有这些剪刀。所以你们都不是左撇子。我是双撇子。我用左手写字，但我用右手扔东西，剪纸。如果你是左撇子，你会不及格幼儿园。他们不提供你需要的必要的左撇子剪刀。所以最近我偶然发现了，最近，就像在我生命中的最后一年，我偶然发现了左撇子剪刀，这绝对是一个游戏规则的改变者。
And then that decision to not go to Texas A&M and go right into the minors, that was a risky decision because like, what if it doesn't work out in the minors? And now, did you think, well, I can always, I'm just a fur enrollment and I can go to Texas A&M later. How does that work? No, it just, I mean, just financial, they just paid me money to go play baseball. So I was in on that. Right. But if it didn't work out, like if tons of guys go to the minors and never make it up to the big game, um, would you have gone back to college?
还有螺旋笔记本，螺旋在另一边。对。所以你不会伤到你的手臂。等等，你会寄给我一个吗？对。我总是对螺旋环和三环活页夹感到生气。对。螺旋在另一边。所以当你像这样写字时，你知道，哦，那看起来你有问题，而且当你写字时，你会把铅笔芯弄得满手都是，看，你懂的。你懂的。
Yeah. Some of those contracts, thankfully that the teams do, they, they, uh, they set aside a little money for you to go to college. Like if it, if you play a certain amount of years and don't make it, they, they set aside a little money for you to go to college. So I think that's great. And they still do that, which is awesome. Wow. That's cool. And what do you think you would have studied? Man, school was not, uh, well, A&M, so you were going to, you were going to do some sort of farming, harvesting, mainly agriculture and mechanical. Um, no, my, my girlfriend
这些都不会出现在播客里。这些都不会。不，得了吧。这很好。对。所以你是左撇子，这已经成为一个问题，因为你差点因为剪刀而被留级。谢谢。达拉斯地区的学校里他们用剪刀剪纸的频率很高。我不记得确切了，但根据我最大的孩子的情况，频率很高。频率很高。
at the time and wife now went to A&M. So she committed to A&M. So I was like, Oh, I'll, I'll jump on the back. God, you said wife now. Yeah. And wife now she's, uh, yeah. Same one. So she, uh, she went to A&M. What she studied there, communication. She was a calm major. Yeah. She's a very good public speaker. That's great. Now, before we leave the football, uh, end of your life, are you one of those big fantasy football guys on the Dodgers that, that you guys do the big draft and all that
不会吧。我想，我的问题呢？发生了什么？对。我试图避免那个，因为我没有答案。好吧。所以是棒球，棒球。不，要么是这个，要么什么都没有。对。我想是这样。我喜欢那个。我也喜欢一个要么全有要么全无的人。我会，因为我也做不了别的事。我没有其他技能。
stuff? Thank you for bringing that up. Cause you gotta start prepping, right? Yeah. We were back to back fantasy football champions. My partner, Ross stripling is my fantasy. Nice. Um, so back to back. That's, now is there a trophy? We have a trophy and I have a base. I'm commissioner of my baseball fantasy league and we, we have a trophy. We ship it around the country for the winners. Thank you. We do have a trophy. We do.
所以对于我们那些对棒球一无所知的听众，或者肖恩，通常你会让一个左撇子投手进来对付一个左撇子击球手，因为这更难，因为球是从你站立的盘子的那一侧飞过来的。所以你会想，伙计，如果我真的想在棒球界作为投手赚很多钱，我会教自己如何用双手投球，对吧？所以你们去年有一个家伙。现在忘了他的名字了。哦，文代蒂，帕特·文代蒂。所以这个家伙专业地用两只手投球。所以你有一个击球手上来，他会，他只是拿过他的手套，把它戴在另一只手上。那是什么？像无拇指手套还是什么奇怪的东西？我想是吧。现在，为什么没有更多那样的投手？而且，而且，为什么他那么，他只是上来喝杯咖啡就走了，对吧？我想，我不知道。这太难了。我是说，没有多少人是双撇子，所以。但你必须学习如何用你的左手投球，当你，你知道。你必须学习吗？还是你只是知道？
You do have a trophy? Yeah. Who fell asleep? I did because Jason talking about being a commissioner of his league, he's a multi-commissioner. Are you still doing, are you still, are you a commissioner? No, I knocked it down to one. I've got a job now. Wait, are you serious? Jason, you're a commissioner of a team? That's right. Oh yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That's right. And I don't take any nonsense. Okay. I booted Oberman
对，但对，你只是拿起球就开始投，对吧？你只是知道。但如果你的父母当时能多想一点，像文代蒂的父母那样，偶尔把球放在你的另一只手上，克莱顿。但如果你是，如果你是总经理阿博特，你别无选择。嘿，不。现在那个，那个相当令人印象深刻。那相当令人印象深刻，不是，不是你对那个名字的深刻理解，但所以肖恩，这是一个只有一只手臂的家伙。
out of the league for mouthing off too much about some of the rules, um, that I like to throw in there. How many, how many arguments have you and Oberman have? We're going to get him on here too. So he can like tell his side, but you and Keith Oberman have had a number of arguments over fantasy baseball. Argument implies that there's a winner and a loser. You can't, there, there's no competition when you argue with him. You just, you're right out of the gate. You're going to lose. So the best thing to do is just boot him out of the league and plus he wins all the time
他们是认真的。对。而且他是一名职业投手。他为天使队投球。作为投手非常成功。对。接下来，我想转到克莱顿。我这里有一个非常重要的问题。我运动时出汗很多，显然，这是一个人身体状况非常好的标志。
too. I told you that when, when I used to play fantasy football in that same league and Keith did, and I tried to make a couple, he claimed to somebody recently that I wouldn't make trades with him. And I'm like, no, no, no, I tried to get him to make trades and then he would not answer me at all. And I was like, well, Because they were offensively beneficial to, to you probably. Well, yeah. Why do you think I wanted to make them? So Clayton, I have a question. You're a left hander, right?
或者吸毒了。我告诉过你，我每场比赛都看。所以我看了你出汗好几年了。你是一个非常，非常会出汗的人。感谢这一点。我有一个关于你们男人被迫在其中比赛的材料的问题。现在我知道你们穿的吸湿排汗内衣这些年来确实取得了很大的进步。所以我，我假设这个问题的答案是它不会困扰你，但看起来制服材料是我这辈子最不想在里面出汗的东西，那种厚重的聚酯纤维，让人发痒的日间比赛噩梦。能，能跟我谈谈大联盟制服的舒适度吗？它们已经进步了很多。顺便说一句，谢谢你问这个问题。它们已经进步了很多。我可能在出汗方面属于过度的一方。所以我知道它不像你需要的那么吸湿。所以，对我来说，有很多制服更换，特别是在日间比赛的情况下。而且我很幸运能在洛杉矶打球，我无法想象，你知道，去圣路易斯，试图在夏天投球。就像我想，我不知道，我不得不不穿制服投球。我是说，根本没有办法做到。所以你会否决去亚特兰大、圣路易斯、任何你那些更热、更厚的气候的交易，对吧？你必须。否则你会脱水。你会抽筋。那会很艰难。我可能会减掉一些体重。那会很好。所以等等，在大型竞技场和电视上，有数百万人在看你，这和表演非常相似。我试图把它和我做的事情联系起来，因为我是个自恋者，是，你有什么疯狂的仪式或者，你知道，像准备工作之类的吗，在比赛之前？就像你做的。我在之前有很多。就像我做百老汇演出什么的。对，我们有。我想，我想我的队友可能会说我也有不少。我只是认为自己非常注重常规。他们会说我有点疯狂，但是的，我确实有很多。你有一些队友，我想他们比你更胜一筹，但我们不谈论他们。对。对。我们会在广告时间做那个。你会说什么是你，什么是你最奇怪的事情，你不会责怪你的一些队友，他们不习惯？嗯，这只是，这只是我的时间安排。就像我，我把一切都安排好了。比如如果是七点十分的比赛，从一点三十七分左右开始，我知道我确切需要做什么。你在开玩笑。你在开玩笑。有那么精确吗？它是，对，它，它，它确实是。我喜欢它。对。我不羞耻。我也喜欢常规。哇。现在我不知道你能多诚实地回答这个问题，但就你所能的程度，你把这个赛季放在你头脑中的什么位置？我是说，我是说，我知道
I'm a left hander. Yes. What's that like? No, I'm kidding. Uh, tell me about like, uh, Is it hard with a forker? Wow. Cause you know, most people are right handed. So I, uh, no, um, but back to like what Will was saying and a little bit with Jason's was saying, like if you went to school, there has to be something else that you would have maybe tried at least or other interests or, you know, what was your, what's the dream
有，有竞争发生，你们是好胜的人。所以无论竞争是什么，让我们赢下它，但在你的脑海里，你把它看作一个真正的赛季，一个真正的世界冠军，一个真正的，还是你们以独特的眼光看待它，并以不同的方式制定策略？回顾过去，你认为你会以不同的方式回顾它，还是现在还为时过早？对。嗯，我想，我想你作为一个球迷可能可以回答这个问题。就像，你把它排在什么位置？对我来说，它有点像，你知道，它，它是不一样的。它不是，它不是一个星号。你知道，它不像，它不像那样，但它，它绝对
other than that? Well, can we go back to the left handed thing? Cause this is kind of a, this is important to me. So there's these scissors. So none of y'all are left handed. I am ambidextrous. I write with my left, but I throw with my right cutting paper. You'll fail kindergarten if you're left handed. They don't supply you with the necessary left handed scissors that you need. And so recently I stumbled upon recently, like within the last year of my life, I stumbled upon left handed scissors and it's been a absolute game changer
和每一年都不一样，显然。所以就像，我不知道。它就像它自己独立的类别。这并不意味着它不会有意义，我们不会享受，你知道，获胜的机会，或者在季后赛中打球的机会，或者类似的事情。但它绝对就像它自己，我是说，没有球迷太，太奇怪了。就像太奇怪了。太奇怪了。这对合同有什么影响？就像他们只是按比例分配，对吧？对，只是按比例分配。对。所以如果你把你的薪水除以162场比赛，你只是，你知道，每场比赛平均，然后你只是为那60场比赛赚取那些。
as well as spiral notebooks with the spirals on the other side. Yeah. So you don't hurt your arm. Wait, would you send me one of those? Yeah. I get pissed off all the time with the spiral rings and the, the three ring binders. Yeah. The spirals on the other side. So when you're writing like this, you know, Oh, that looks like you have a problem and you get, and you get the pencil lead all over your hand when you, when you write, See, you get it. You get it.
对。明白了。好吧。所以克莱顿，我想问你一个有点像第三轨的问题，但我不会问你那些你可能不想回答的部分。我想谈谈棒球中的作弊。现在投手丘上的遮嘴。好吧。嗯，你们把手套放在脸前，这样人们在你们互相交谈时就读不出你们的唇语。你在联盟待了12年，我觉得这可能只发生了10年左右。所以我问你，作为一个在它之前，现在在它之后参与比赛的人，读唇语真的那么普遍吗，以至于每个人在说话时都必须遮住他们该死的嘴？就像作弊那么严重吗？当威尔和我说话时，我用手遮住我的脸，因为我不想看到他。那真的就是全部。对。它太像，听着，伙计们，这又不是中央情报局。让我们只是谈谈我们要把暗号从这个改成那个，然后回到盘子。你知道，手套怎么了？嗯，我是说，如果你在体育场内，或者如果你在更衣室里，你看到教练和捕手或投手说话，他说，嘿，把暗号改成第二个暗号，他们在电视上看到了。你难道不去告诉你的队友是第二个暗号吗？你会做的。
None of this is going to be in the podcast. None of this. No, come on. This is good. Yeah. So you're a left hander, which has been an issue by virtue of the fact that you were almost held back because of scissors. Thank you. How much cutting with scissors they do at the schools in the Dallas area is a lot. I don't remember exactly, but based on my oldest, it's a lot. It's a lot.
但这就是重点。假设是任何在会所里看电视的人都能读唇语。人们能读吗？你可以读那个。但他不会那样做。他不会发音清晰，以便读唇语的人能。这不是猜谜游戏，他们不必猜。但就像他们在过去的日子里没这样做。两个词以第一，第二开头。我只是，我很想看到有人只是说去他的，挑战读唇语的人，然后停止那些动作。伙计，我没意识到这对你来说是个大问题。我会和他谈谈。嗯，现在它，它正在蔓延到其他运动，克莱顿。这是一个真正的，它是一个问题。橄榄球也是，哈？橄榄球。他们有大的，比如，对。
No way. I want to, what about my question? What happened? Yeah. I'm trying to avoid that because I don't have an answer to that one. Okay. So it's baseball, baseball. No, it was this or nothing. Yeah. I think so. I love that. I love an all or nothing person too. I would, because I can't do anything else either. I have no other skills.
对。但你，但教练在橄榄球场边一直这样做，他们拿着战术板。你在他们脸前有一张小卡片。对。你讨厌那个吗？我讨厌。我只是觉得他们都太，你知道，嗯，对。现在，你知道，我们的，我们的休斯顿的朋友，嗯，引起了，引起了一点担忧，但我不是，这不是以问题的形式。嗯，我们只是让它停在那里。好吧。让我看看。安静地。别人得问个问题。非常感谢。好吧。所以我有一个问题。嗯，现在这可能会，这可能必须被剪掉，因为这真的会显示我是多么的SmartLess，我是多么的愚蠢。什么是棒球？所以当芝加哥
So for our listener out there that doesn't know anything about baseball or Sean, usually you have a left handed pitcher come in and pitch against a left handed hitter cause it's harder because the ball's coming from the side of the plate that you're standing on. So you would think, boy, if I really want to make a lot of money in baseball as a pitcher, I'd teach myself how to throw with both hands, right? So you guys had a guy last year. Forget his name now. Oh, Vendetti, Pat Vendetti. So this guy threw professionally with both arms. So you have a batter come up and he'd
小熊队在800年后终于赢得了世界大赛，他们当时在打道奇队，对吧？嗯，对。我在他们赢得世界大赛之前让他们赢得了系列赛。对。好吧。好吧。明白了。准备好了吗，肖恩。谢谢那个。不错。不错，肖恩。不，不。嗯，不，因为没关系。因为我是芝加哥人，就像眼泪顺着我的脸流下来，我就想，哦，天哪，我不敢相信白袜队赢了，白袜队。我不敢相信他们在最后投进了一个三分球。这简直令人难以置信。但，嗯，不，但，嗯，接近一个问题。道奇队当时不是有点，比如，我明白了。继续。显然你试图赢，但一旦小熊队赢了，你难道没有一种，比如，他们赢了真是太棒了的感觉吗？
just take his glove and he put it on the other hand. What was it? Like a thumbless glove or something weird like that? I guess so. Now, why aren't there more pitchers like that? And, and, and why was he so like he just came up for a cup of coffee and that was it, right? I think, I don't know. It's so hard. I mean, not many people are ambidextrous, so. But you had to learn how to throw with your left hand when you were, you know. Do you have to learn though? Or you just know?
只是拿过他的手套，然后戴在另一只手上。那是什么？像无拇指手套还是什么奇怪的东西？我想是吧。那么，为什么没有更多那样的投手呢？而且，为什么他就像昙花一现，露个面就没了，对吧？我想，我不知道。这太难了。我的意思是，没几个人是左右手通用的，所以。但你必须在小时候就学会用左手投球。你必须学吗？还是你天生就会？
Yeah, but yeah, you just picked up the ball and started throwing, right? You just know. But if your parents had just been thinking a little bit more like Vendetti's parents and put the ball on your other hand every once in a while, Clayton. But if you're, if you're GM Abbott, you have no choice. Hey, no. Now that, that was pretty impressive. Was that pretty impressive with not, not your deep cut on that name, but so Sean, this was a guy with one arm.
是啊，但你就是拿起球就开始投了，对吧？你天生就会。但如果你的父母能像文迪蒂（Vendetti）的父母那样多想一点，偶尔把球换到你另一只手上，克莱顿。但如果你是阿博特（Abbott）总经理，你就没得选了。嘿，不。那确实令人印象深刻。那真的很令人印象深刻，不是说你对那个名字有多了解，而是肖恩，这是一个只有一只手臂的家伙。
They're being serious. Yeah. And he was a professional pitcher. He threw for the angels. Very successful as a pitcher. Yeah. Next, I want to move to Clayton. I've got a very important question here. I sweat a great deal when I, when I exercise, apparently it's, it's the mark of somebody who's in very good shape.
他们是认真的。是的。他是一名职业投手。他为天使队投球。作为投手非常成功。是的。接下来，我想谈谈克莱顿。我这里有一个非常重要的问题。我运动时会出很多汗，显然，这是身体素质非常好的人的标志。
Or on drugs. I told you, I watch every game. So I've watched you sweat for years. You're a great, great sweater. Appreciate that. I have a question about the material that you men are forced to play in. Now I know that the wicking under material that you guys wear has really made great strides over the years. So I'm, I'm assuming the answer to this question is it doesn't bother you, but it looks like the uniform material is about the, the last thing in the world I'd want to sweat in that
或者是吸毒了。我告诉过你，我看了每一场比赛。所以我看了你出汗好几年了。你是个非常、非常能出汗的人。谢谢。我有一个关于你们这些男人被迫穿着比赛的材料的问题。我知道你们穿的排汗内衣这些年来确实取得了很大的进步。所以我假设这个问题的答案是它不会困扰你，但看起来球衣材料是我这辈子最不想在出汗时穿的东西，那个
thick polyester scratchy day game nightmare. Can, can you talk to me a little bit about the comfort level in major league uniforms? They've come a long way. Thank you for asking about this, by the way. They've come a long way. I am probably on the excessive side of sweating. So I know that it doesn't wick as much as you need it to. So there's, there's plenty of uniform changes for me, especially in a day game situation. And as fortunate as I am to play in LA, I can't imagine, you know, going to St. Louis and trying to pitch in the summer. Like I think I don't, I would have to pitch with
厚聚酯纤维、磨人的日间比赛噩梦。你能跟我聊聊大联盟球衣的舒适度吗？它们已经进步了很多。顺便说一句，谢谢你问这个问题。它们确实进步了很多。我出汗可能属于过量的那种。所以我知道它排汗效果没那么好。所以对我来说，球衣要换很多次，尤其是在日间比赛的情况下。而且尽管我很幸运能在洛杉矶打球，但我无法想象去圣路易斯在夏天投球。我觉得我可能不得不
no uniform. I mean, there's just no way to do it. So you would veto a trade to Atlanta, St. Louis, any of, any of your hotter, thicker climates, right? You'd have to. Otherwise you're going to dehydrate. You're going to cramp up. It would be tough. I would probably lose some weight though. It'd be good. So wait a minute, playing sports and a big arena and on television with all these millions of people watching you is very similar to performing. I was trying to relate it back to what I do because I'm a narcissist is, is, do you have any crazy rituals or, you
不穿球衣投球。我的意思是，根本没法穿。所以你会否决去亚特兰大、圣路易斯或任何更热、更潮湿气候地区的交易，对吧？你必须这么做。否则你会脱水。你会抽筋。那会很艰难。不过我可能会瘦一点。那倒不错。等等，在大型体育场和电视上，在数百万人的注视下进行体育比赛，这和表演非常相似。我试图把它和我做的事情联系起来，因为我是个自恋者，你有任何疯狂的仪式吗，或者
know, like preparations or anything like that before a game? Like that you do. I have tons of them before. Like I do a Broadway show or something. Yeah, we do. I think, I think my teammates would probably say that I have quite a few as well. I just consider myself to be very routine oriented. They would say that I'm a little crazy, but yes, I do have quite a bit. You've had some teammates that I think beat you to that, but we won't talk about them. Yeah. Yeah. We'll do that during the commercial break. What would you say is your, is your weirdest
你知道，比如赛前的准备工作之类的？你做的那些。我在百老汇演出前有很多。是的，我们有。我想我的队友可能会说我也有不少。我只是认为自己非常注重常规。他们会说我有点疯狂，但确实，我有很多。你有一些队友我想比你更甚，但我们就不提他们了。是的。是的。我们会在广告时间聊这个。你会说你最奇怪的是什么
thing that you wouldn't blame some of your teammates that they're not used to? Well, it's just the, it's just my timing. Like I have, I have everything down. Like if it's a game at seven, 10, starting at about like 137, I know exactly what I need to do. You're joking. You're joking. Is it that precise? It's, yeah, it's, it's, yeah, it is. I love it. Yeah. I'm not ashamed. I love routines too. Wow. Now I don't know how honestly you can answer this question, but to the extent that you can, how do you, where do you put this season in your head? I mean, like, I mean, I know
你不会怪你的队友不习惯的事情？嗯，就是我的时间安排。我把一切都安排得井井有条。如果比赛是七点十分开始，我大约一点三十七分就知道我该做什么了。你在开玩笑吧。你在开玩笑吧。有那么精确吗？是的，确实如此。我喜欢这样。是的。我不觉得羞耻。我也喜欢常规。哇。现在我不知道你能多诚实地回答这个问题，但就你所能回答的程度，你心里是怎么看待这个赛季的？我的意思是，我知道
there's, there's a competition happening and you guys are competitive people. So let's win it no matter what the competition is, but in your mind, do you see it as a true season, as a true world championship, as a true, or are you guys looking at it uniquely and sort of strategizing differently? And in retrospect, do you think you'll look back at it differently or is it still too soon? Yeah. Well, I think, I think you could probably answer that as a fan. Just like, where do you rank it? For me, it's kind of like, you know, it's, it's different. It's not, it's not an asterisk. You know, it's not like, it's not like that, but it's, it's definitely
比赛正在进行，你们都是好胜的人。所以无论比赛是什么，我们都要赢，但在你心里，你认为这是一个真正的赛季，一个真正的世界冠军赛，还是你们以独特的眼光看待它，并以不同的方式制定策略？回想起来，你认为你会以不同的方式看待它，还是现在说还太早？是的，嗯，我想作为一个球迷你可能能回答这个问题。你把它排在什么位置？对我来说，它有点像，你知道，它很特别。它不是，它不是一个星号。你知道，它不像那样，但它绝对
different than every other year, obviously. So like, I don't know. It's like its own separate category. It doesn't mean that it's not going to be meaningful and we're not going to enjoy, you know, the chance to win or the opportunity to play in the playoffs or things like that. But it's definitely like its own, I mean, no fans is so, is so weird. Like it's so weird. It's so weird. And how does this affect contracts? Like they just pro rate it, right? Yeah, just pro rate it. Yeah. So if you divide your salary up into 162 games and you just, you know, per game average and, and then you just make those for the 60 games.
和往年不同，显然。所以，我不知道。它就像一个独立的类别。这并不意味着它没有意义，我们不会享受赢得比赛的机会，或者在季后赛中打球的机会之类的。但它绝对是它自己的，我的意思是，没有球迷真是太奇怪了。真是太奇怪了。真是太奇怪了。这对合同有什么影响？他们只是按比例分配，对吧？是的，按比例分配。是的。所以如果你把你的薪水除以162场比赛，然后你只是，你知道，按每场比赛的平均值，然后你只是赚取那60场比赛的钱。
Yeah. Got it. All right. So Clayton, I want to ask you a question that's a little bit of a third rail, but I'm not going to ask you the part that you probably don't want to answer. I want to talk about cheating in baseball. Now the mouth covering on mound huddles. Okay. Well, you guys put your mitts up in front of your face so that people can't read your lips when you're talking to each other. You've been in the league 12 years and I feel like it's only been going on for maybe 10 years. So I'm asking you as somebody who has been a part of the game before it and now after is lip reading really that pervasive where everyone's
是的。明白了。好吧，克莱顿，我想问你一个有点敏感的问题，但我不会问你可能不想回答的那部分。我想谈谈棒球中的作弊。现在投手丘上的遮嘴讨论。好吧。你们把手套放在脸前，这样别人就读不出你们在说什么了。你在联盟待了12年，我觉得这种情况可能只持续了10年左右。所以我问你，作为一个在它之前和之后都参与过比赛的人，读唇语真的那么普遍吗，以至于每个人
got to cover their G damn mouth when they're talking. Like is cheating that bad? I cover my face with my hand when Will talks to me because I don't want to see him. That's really all it is. Yeah. It's so like, listen, gang, like this isn't the CIA. Let's just talk about we're going to change a sign from this to that and get back to the plate. You know, what's going on with the glove? Well, I mean, if you're inside the stadium or if you're in the locker room and you see the coach talking to the catcher or the pitcher and he says, Hey, change the signs to second sign and they see that on the TV. Are you not going to go tell your teammates that it's second sign? You're going to do it.
在说话时都得遮住他们该死的嘴？作弊真的那么严重吗？当威尔跟我说话时，我用手遮住脸，因为我不想看到他。真的就只是这样。是的。所以，听着，伙计们，这又不是中央情报局。我们只是讨论一下我们要把暗号从这个改成那个，然后回到本垒板。你知道，手套是怎么回事？嗯，我的意思是，如果你在体育场内，或者在更衣室里，你看到教练在和捕手或投手说话，他说，嘿，把暗号改成第二个暗号，他们在电视上看到了。你难道不去告诉你的队友是第二个暗号吗？你会做的。
But that's just it. The assumption is that whoever's watching the TV in the clubhouse can read lips. Can people second? You can read that. But he's not going to do it like that. He's not going to enunciate so that the lip readers can. It's not charades where they have to guess. But like they didn't do it back in the old days. Two words starts with first, second. I just, I'd love to see somebody just say screw it and challenge the lip readers and just stop with the men. Man, I didn't realize that was such a big issue for you. I'll talk to him. Well, now it's, it's spreading to other sports, Clayton. It's a real, it's an issue. Football too, huh? Football. They have the big like, yeah.
但问题就在这里。假设是任何在会所看电视的人都能读唇语。人们能吗？第二个？你能读懂那个。但他不会那样做。他不会说得那么清楚，让读唇语的人能读懂。这不是猜谜游戏，他们不需要去猜。但他们过去不这样做。两个词，以第一、第二开头。我只是，我很想看到有人说去他的，挑战那些读唇语的人，停止用手套遮挡。伙计，我没意识到这对你来说是个大问题。我会跟他谈谈的。嗯，现在它正在蔓延到其他运动中，克莱顿。这是一个真正的问题。橄榄球也是，对吧？橄榄球。他们有那种大的，是的。
Yeah. But you, but what about coaches do it in football on the sidelines all the time where they're holding the play? You have a little card in front of their face. Yeah. Do you hate that? I do. I just think they're all so, you know, well, yeah. Now, you know, our, our friends in Houston, um, gave, gave cause to a little bit of concern, but I'm not, this is not in a question form. Um, and we'll just let it rest there. Okay. Let me see. Quietly. Somebody else got to ask a question. Thanks so much. Okay. So I have a question. Um, now this is going to, this may have to get cut because this is going to really show how smartless I am and stupid I am. What's baseball? So when the Chicago
是的。但在橄榄球比赛中，教练在场边一直这样做，他们拿着战术板。你面前有一张小卡片遮住脸。是的。你讨厌那样吗？我讨厌。我只是觉得他们都太，你知道，好吧，是的。现在，你知道，我们在休斯顿的朋友，嗯，引起了一点担忧，但我不是，这不是以问题的形式提出的，嗯，我们就让它到此为止吧。好的。让我看看。安静地。别人得问个问题。非常感谢。好的。所以我有一个问题。嗯，现在这可能得剪掉，因为这真的会显示我有多无知和愚蠢。什么是棒球？所以当芝加哥
Cubs finally won the World Series after 800 years, they were playing the Dodgers, right? Uh, yeah. I let them win the series before they won the World Series. Yeah. Okay. Okay. Got it. Ready to go, Sean. Thanks for that. Nice. Nice, Sean. No, no. Well, no, because it's fine. Because I'm from Chicago and like tears are rolling down my face and I was like, Oh my God, I can't believe the white sucks one, the white. I can't believe they scored a three pointer in the end. It was just unbelievable. But, uh, no, but, um, closing in on a question. Weren't the Dodgers a little bit kind of like, I get it. Go ahead. Obviously you try to win, but once the Cubs won, weren't you kind of like, it's pretty awesome that they won.
小熊队在800年后终于赢得了世界大赛，他们当时是在和道奇队比赛，对吧？呃，是的。我让他们在赢得世界大赛之前赢得了系列赛。是的。好的。好的。明白了。准备好了吗，肖恩。谢谢。不错。不错，肖恩。不，不。嗯，不，因为没关系。因为我来自芝加哥，眼泪顺着我的脸流下来，我就像，哦天哪，我不敢相信白袜队赢了，白袜队。我不敢相信他们在最后投进了一个三分球。这真是令人难以置信。但是，嗯，不，但是，嗯，接近一个问题。道奇队当时不是有点，我明白了。继续。显然你努力去赢，但一旦小熊队赢了，你难道没有觉得他们赢了真是太棒了吗？
No. No. All right. Next question. No, no, I, um, maybe looking back, I see where you're going with that. Like you think the Dodgers just said, well, if we're going to lose, let's lose to the biggest losers in the history of baseball. That makes, yeah, right. No, but I mean, of course you try to win. Of course you played your best. Of course you shined. It was incredible game. It was unbelievable. But come on, the Cubs hadn't won in like, you know, centuries. Yeah. I mean, I think the only thing I think when a team beats you, I think subconsciously it's like, well, if they end up winning the World Series, then like we at least lost to the best team. Right. Makes you guys look better. Yeah. Yeah. We
不。不。好吧。下一个问题。不，不，我，嗯，也许回过头来看，我明白你的意思了。就像你认为道奇队只是说，好吧，如果我们注定要输，那就输给棒球史上最大的输家吧。这说得通，对吧。不，但我的意思是，你当然会努力去赢。你当然会尽力而为。你当然会大放异彩。那是一场精彩的比赛。简直不可思议。但是拜托，小熊队已经有，你知道，几个世纪没赢过了。是啊。我的意思是，我想当一支球队击败你时，我潜意识里想的是，好吧，如果他们最终赢得了世界大赛，那么我们至少是输给了最强的球队。对吧。这让你们看起来好受些。是啊。是啊。我们
lost to the world's best. So playing in Wrigley, playing in Fenway, Dodger Stadium, third oldest. Um, I'm sure you have some favorite stadiums. Um, is there a consensus amongst the players of what the best, because I heard the Dodgers won this for a few years by the groundskeepers. What field has, is in the best shape usually constantly, like gets the best, the truest roles. There's no hard spots. There's no, is Dodger Stadium still Jason's into gardening. Jason's. Yeah. I'll bring everything around the green thumb. Um, I've got some hydrangeas that are today to die. Um, who's got the best field? Um, yeah. So every guy kind of has their favorite spot, right? Like favorite city to go to is usually not their favorite
输给了世界上最强的球队。所以，在瑞格利球场、芬威球场、道奇体育场打球，这是第三古老的球场。嗯，我相信你一定有一些最喜欢的体育场。嗯，球员们对于哪个球场最好有共识吗？因为我听说道奇队因为场地管理员的原因，连续几年赢得了这个奖项。哪个球场通常一直保持在最佳状态，比如能得到最好的、最真实的球路反馈？没有硬点。没有，道奇体育场还是杰森在负责园艺吗？杰森的。是啊。我会把所有关于园艺的东西都带过来。嗯，我有一些绣球花，今天简直美极了。嗯，谁的球场最好？嗯，是啊。每个人都有自己喜欢的场地，对吧？就像最喜欢的城市通常不是他们最喜欢的
city to play in, you know, like you want to go to New York, you want to go to Chicago to, you know, hang out, go to dinner, all that stuff. And like favorite playing surface is usually like California cause it's just the best weather. So most of the California fields are field is unbelievable. San Diego is really nice. Anaheim, although they have perfect weather. So I think that, and then, um, Love the way it didn't mention the giants. I love it. Keep going. See, I don't, I don't know. They don't even exist. They don't even exist. I think, I think, I think LA and San Diego are the two best. Got it. Now you're not going out at night though. You said some
打球的城市，你知道，就像你想去纽约，你想去芝加哥，你知道，去逛逛，去吃晚餐，所有这些事情。而最喜欢的比赛场地通常是加州，因为那里的天气最好。所以大多数加州的球场，场地简直不可思议。圣地亚哥的真的很好。阿纳海姆，尽管他们有完美的天气。所以我认为，然后，嗯，喜欢你没提到巨人队的方式。我喜欢。继续。看，我，我不知道。他们甚至不存在。他们甚至不存在。我想，我想，我想洛杉矶和圣地亚哥是最好的两个。明白了。不过你晚上不出门，你说过一些
cities you like to go. You're not going out after the game and getting all crazy, right? Well, not this year, right? But I mean, any year you can't go to dinner, you go, you go hang out, go to dinner. Have you ever played with a hangover? You don't have to answer that. You don't have to answer that garbage. 48 hour rule. It's part of my routine. No, no drinking two days before. Is there any truth to Juan Uribe and uh, Yossio Pueg having matching white Rolls Royces doing donuts in the parking lot at Dodger Stadium? What? I've never heard this before. Did they have matching white Rolls Royces? White Rolls Royces are true. That's true. They both had those, but you never
你喜欢的城市。你比赛后不会出去玩得很疯，对吧？嗯，今年不行，对吧？但我的意思是，任何一年你都不能去吃晚餐，你去，你去逛逛，去吃晚餐。你曾经宿醉打过球吗？你不必回答那个。你不必回答那种垃圾问题。48小时规则。这是我例行公事的一部分。不，比赛前两天不喝酒。胡安·乌里韦和亚希尔·普伊格在道奇体育场停车场开着配套的白色劳斯莱斯玩漂移，这事是真的吗？什么？我以前从没听说过这个。他们有配套的白色劳斯莱斯吗？白色劳斯莱斯是真的。那是真的。他们俩都有那些，但你从来没
heard about them doing donuts. They must have. I love they had matching. I love that. That's true. Why would you do it in that car? Because Rolls Royces can get up and get after it. Oh, I didn't know. That's, that's what I understand. Um, all right. Beyond ping pong, what is your, what's your best other sport? Football? Oh, ping pong. I wish she didn't say besides ping pong. I don't really have another best. By the way, I play killer ping pong. I'm not even kidding. And I'm going to do it. Do you really? Yeah. He'll wax you. I played it up since I was a kid. Don't, don't mess with him. He'll, he'll really embarrass you. I'll fuck you up. I will. Oh, ping pong. Did you. So I know you, you hosted the Ellen show for
听说过他们玩漂移。他们肯定玩过。我喜欢他们有配套的车。我喜欢这一点。那是真的。你为什么要在那种车上做这种事？因为劳斯莱斯也能跑得很快。哦，我不知道。那是，那是我的理解。嗯，好吧。除了乒乓球，你，你最擅长的其他运动是什么？橄榄球？哦，乒乓球。我希望她没说除了乒乓球。我真的没有其他最擅长的了。顺便说一句，我乒乓球打得超好。我没开玩笑。而且我会去打的。你真的吗？是啊。他会把你打得落花流水。我从小就一直在打。别，别惹他。他会，他会让你很尴尬的。我会把你打爆的。我会的。哦，乒乓球。你有没有。所以我知道你主持过艾伦秀
a little bit and I got to be on the Ellen show and play with Ellen a little bit and she's super competitive about that too. Is she any good at that? Word on the street is. Yeah. Yeah. She's not belly. Yeah. No, but I, I'm serious. I want to, Jason, I want to do that. I want to do the ping pong thing. I'd love to have you. Well, the next year, if you're nice to Clayton, he'll invite you. Yeah. I would love that. And Kim will host it every once in a while. Yeah. He's hosted it before for sure. And what's the, what's the charity? So it's our charity, Kershaw's challenge is the name of it. And every year we have kind of different beneficiaries and just kind of raise money for different places here in LA
一小会儿，我有幸上了艾伦秀，和艾伦玩了一会儿，她对那个也超级有胜负欲。她打得好吗？坊间传闻是。是啊。是啊。她不是那种花架子。是啊。不，但我，我是认真的。我想，杰森，我想做那个。我想做乒乓球那个活动。我很乐意邀请你。嗯，明年，如果你对克莱顿好一点，他会邀请你的。是啊。我很乐意。而且金偶尔会主持它。是啊。他以前肯定主持过。那，那慈善活动是什么？所以这是我们的慈善机构，名字叫克肖挑战。每年我们都有不同的受益人，只是为洛杉矶的这些不同地方筹集资金
and Dallas and kind of everywhere really. That's great. You guys still have a facility and an effort down in Zambia. I think it is. Is that right? Yeah. That's kind of where it got started. My wife's been going to Africa. She's been nine or 10 times now. And yeah, long story short, that's kind of how the charity got started with one girl over there named Hope who's, who's doing great now, which is, which is cool to see. Do you guys keep your eyes open for other areas around the world or even domestically here that, that could benefit from money or attention? Like, is that kind of an ongoing effort? Or do you guys focus on, on the, the one place there in, in Africa?
和达拉斯，以及实际上到处都是。那太棒了。你们在赞比亚还有一个设施和一个项目，我想是这样。对吗？是啊。那算是它开始的地方。我妻子一直在去非洲。她现在已经去了九或十次了。而且，长话短说，这就是慈善机构开始的方式，和一个在那边叫霍普的女孩有关，她现在做得很好，这，这看起来很酷。你们会留意世界各地甚至国内其他可能从金钱或关注中受益的领域吗？比如，这是一种持续的努力吗？还是你们专注于，在非洲的那个地方？
Yeah. So every year we have like grant applications come in, but basically we're trying to focus on, you know, our hometowns, which is LA and Dallas. And then we have something with international justice mission in the Dominican Republic that I've been down there a few times and just really love what they're doing. And then Zambia is kind of every year. So we always do something with the rise Africa in Zambia, but the local nonprofits in LA and Dallas are always changing, just trying to meet tangible needs wherever we see it. That's so awesome. You guys are going to skip a bunch of lines upstairs when you're all done with this.
是啊。所以每年我们都有像拨款申请进来，但基本上我们试图专注于，你知道，我们的家乡，也就是洛杉矶和达拉斯。然后我们在多米尼加共和国有一个与国际正义使命团合作的项目，我去过那里几次，真的很喜欢他们正在做的事情。然后赞比亚算是每年都有。所以我们总是和赞比亚的“崛起非洲”做一些事情，但洛杉矶和达拉斯当地的非营利组织总是在变化，只是试图在我们看到的地方满足实际需求。那太棒了。你们做完这些后，在上面会跳过很多排队的人。
Jason, would you say that you ever miss an opportunity to skip a line? He wants to talk about the iPhone again. All right. Now you're a long ways away from retiring, but what would your ideal post baseball career look like? Is it, you think just generally is it, is it in baseball? Is it like broadcasting? Is it coaching? Is it, you know, ping pong? There's a lot of money in champion ping ponging. Is it really? I think that's what it's called too. Ping ponging.
杰森，你会说你曾经错过跳过排队的机会吗？他又想谈论iPhone了。好吧。现在你离退役还很远，但你理想的棒球后职业生涯是什么样的？你认为通常是在棒球界吗？是像广播吗？是教练吗？是，你知道，乒乓球吗？冠军乒乓球里有很多钱。真的吗？我想那也是它的名字。乒乓球。
Champion ping pong. Do you know when I was a kid, I played a game called canip canop where the balls go through this little thing. And just a year ago, I realized it was ping pong backwards. Go ahead. Hey, Sean. Yeah. You okay buddy? I'm okay. Do you, I bet whatever it is, it's going to be something that's going to keep you home.
冠军乒乓球。你知道我小时候玩过一个叫canip canop的游戏，球穿过这个小东西。就在一年前，我意识到那是乒乓球的倒写。继续。嘿，肖恩。是啊。你还好吗伙计？我很好。你，我敢打赌无论是什么，它都会是让你留在家里做的事情。
So it's probably not going to be being a bench coach or a manager or any sort of traveling with the team. Yeah. I wouldn't expect to travel much once I retire. I'd still love to like be involved somehow. You know, there's this role that every team has called a special assistant, which is awesome. Yeah. They just let guys come and hang out for a few days at a time. Now, who's got that right now? Cause Sandy Kofax or Chase Utley is a special assistant. Yeah. Chase has got a maid. It's a great gig. The Dodgers have so many. I can't even tell
所以它可能不会是做替补教练或经理，或者任何随队旅行的工作。是啊。我退役后不指望经常旅行。我仍然很乐意以某种方式参与其中。你知道，每支球队都有一个叫特别助理的角色，这很棒。是啊。他们只是让球员们一次来待几天。现在，谁有这个职位？因为桑迪·科法克斯或蔡斯·厄特利是特别助理。是啊。蔡斯有一个。这是一个很棒的工作。道奇队有太多了。我甚至无法告诉你
you, I never see them, but they're special assistants, but they're, they're, they're around all the time. What, what are the job requirements of that special assistant? Yeah. What do they do? That's, I don't know. Yeah. Special assistant's a great gig. That's why it's such a great gig. You get a few laminates, a check, a little bit of respect.
我从没见过他们，但他们是特别助理，但他们，他们，他们一直都在。那个特别助理的工作要求是什么？是啊。他们做什么？那个，我不知道。是啊。特别助理是个很棒的工作。这就是为什么它是个很棒的工作。你得到几张证件，一张支票，一点尊重。
You had to be good when you played and you had, people had to like you when you played. So like Chase was obviously the man and we, we love Chase. And so he's, he's got a great gig with us now. He's got a very dry sense of humor, doesn't he? I mean, I've only met him a couple of times, but that's what I, He didn't talk much, but it's, it's funny. Has there been any really great new clubhouse prank over the years? Cause like hot foot and bubble gum on the hat and all that, there's some good ones, but
你打球时必须很出色，而且，人们必须在你打球时喜欢你。所以就像蔡斯显然是那个男人，我们，我们爱蔡斯。所以他现在在我们这里有一份很棒的工作。他有一种非常冷幽默感，不是吗？我的意思是，我只见过他几次，但这就是我，他不怎么说话，但它，它很有趣。这些年来有什么真正伟大的更衣室恶作剧吗？因为像烫脚和帽子上的泡泡糖之类的，有一些好的，但是
It's been done. Yeah. I don't, I don't mean to ridicule them cause I'm doing it well. I'm sure it's probably a fine art, but have you been impressed with any of these, these young whipper snappers coming up out of minor leagues with some new kind of, wow, never thought of that. Man, you know, we don't, to be honest, short answers, no, we don't have any great pranks. I think sometimes with like, when we have famous people come in the clubhouse and things like that, we try to think of some different things that we can do.
已经做过了。是啊。我，我不是要嘲笑他们，因为我做得很好。我相信这可能是一门精美的艺术，但你有没有对这些从二线联盟上来的年轻小伙子们印象深刻，他们有一些新的，哇，从来没想过那种。伙计，你知道，我们不，老实说，简短的回答是，没有，我们没有任何伟大的恶作剧。我想有时当有名人来到更衣室之类的时候，我们会尝试想一些我们可以做的不同的事情。
Here we go. Yeah. You know, just some things to make him feel maybe a little bit, you know, uncomfortable or things like that. But So, so go ahead and tell, tell Sean the story and will, if you're still with, I don't know what you're talking about. Yeah.
开始了。是啊。你知道，只是为了让他感觉也许有一点，你知道，不舒服之类的事情。但是，所以，所以继续告诉，告诉肖恩那个故事，威尔，如果你还在，我不知道你在说什么。是啊。
I want to hear this really bad. Go. I'll let Jason tell it. I've made a bad decision to go down and you know, I've never, it wasn't a bad decision. Well, it, it was colorful and I'll never forget it. Sean Cassin, who is president of the team, is a very, very nice man and does me a huge, huge favor of talking to me when he sees me every once in a while. He offered to take me and my buddy down to the clubhouse after a win, one game, he said,
我真的很想听这个。说吧。我让杰森说。我做了一个糟糕的决定去下面，你知道，我从来没，那不是一个糟糕的决定。嗯，它，它很生动，我永远不会忘记它。肖恩·卡森，他是球队的总裁，是一个非常，非常善良的人，并且在我偶尔见到他时和我说话，给了我一个巨大，巨大的恩惠。他提出在一场比赛获胜后带我和我的哥们去更衣室，他说，
you got to see this. What buddy? What buddy? I believe it. Does it even remember? Wow. It's going to come to me. Either one of us.
你一定要看看这个。什么哥们？什么哥们？我相信它。甚至还记得吗？哇。它会想起来的。我们俩中的任何一个。
So, so Stan brings me and my buddy, I think it was Steve Brill actually, down to the clubhouse and there was a, so sure enough, they had, they had won all the lights are out in the clubhouse and I just see these like a flash of flash every once in a while, kind of goes through a pool of light and then, and then I look a little closer and the door's kind of open and sure enough, there's a buttock and, and I, I'm not sure if a Schwanz goes by or not, but it's there's dancing going, there's a lot of bouncing, a lot of pink bouncing and, and Stan kicks the door open and sure enough, there is, there's a disco ball going, I think there was a smoke machine maybe, or maybe that was just steam coming
所以，所以斯坦带我和我的哥们，我想其实是史蒂夫·布里尔，去了更衣室，那里有一个，果然，他们，他们赢了，更衣室里所有的灯都关了，我只是偶尔看到这些像闪光一样的东西，穿过一池光，然后，然后我仔细看了看，门是开着的，果然，有一个屁股，而且，我，我不确定是否有一个阴茎经过，但它有跳舞在进行，有很多弹跳，很多粉红色的弹跳，而且，斯坦把门踢开了，果然，那里，有一个迪斯科球在转，我想可能有一个烟雾机，或者也许那只是从淋浴间出来的蒸汽
out of the shower. So these are clean bodies that are naked and dancing, but they're all super happy and they're all, and they're all holding one another and bouncing around in a huddle. I think I have that movie. And somebody, maybe it was you, Clayton, but I was, somebody said, somebody said, Bateman, get in here. And I was so thrilled that somebody on the Los Angeles Dodgers actually knew my name. I sprinted in, now, luckily I didn't start peeling my clothes off, but, but I, I did
出来。所以这些是干净的身体，赤身裸体在跳舞，但他们都超级开心，他们都，而且他们都互相抱着，在人群中跳来跳去。我想我有那部电影。有人，也许是你，克莱顿，但我当时是，有人说，有人说，贝特曼，进来。我太激动了，洛杉矶道奇队竟然有人知道我的名字。我冲了进去，现在，幸运的是我没有开始脱衣服，但是，但是，我，我确实
get grabbed, I'll say, and not a pejorative term, but I partook in the bouncing a little bit. But that's hilarious. Is this like a Clayton, is this a normal thing? That was an interesting year. That was an interesting year. We haven't had too many, you know, you always try to celebrate wins, obviously, cause that's hard to do.
被抓住了，我会说，而不是一个贬义词，但我确实参与了一点弹跳。但这太搞笑了。这是像克莱顿，这是一个正常的事情吗？那是一个有趣的一年。那是一个有趣的一年。我们没有太多，你知道，你总是试图庆祝胜利，显然，因为那很难做到。
Clearly. Now, who, who was a ringleader in there for the, the naked bounces? It was Yossiel, um, was it, uh, Grandal? Maybe it was Grandal. Oh, I think, I'd probably go Pweeg. I think Yossiel was probably the ringleader in that. Um, if I had to guess, it was probably Pweeg. I can't remember exactly.
显然。现在，谁，谁是里面那个裸体弹跳的带头人？是亚希尔，嗯，是，呃，格兰达尔？也许是格兰达尔。哦，我想，我可能会选普伊格。我想亚希尔可能是那个带头人。嗯，如果我必须猜的话，那可能是普伊格。我不记得确切了。
That's a festive room. Do you guys really, you guys don't really party after every single win. No, but just for like a brief minute, you know, turn on the music and, I'm sure you don't have the disco ball anymore. I don't know what happened to that, but that was a great ad. I need to bring that back this year. Who gets to pick the music? Great question.
那是一个喜庆的房间。你们真的，你们不是真的在每次胜利后都聚会。不，但只是为了像短暂的一分钟，你知道，打开音乐，而且，我相信你不再有那个迪斯科球了。我不知道那个怎么了，但那是一个很棒的补充。我今年需要把它带回来。谁来选音乐？好问题。
Uh, every clubhouse is different. Um, sometimes you kind of let guys, you know, take turns, um, but I would say our clubhouse is pretty, you know, we just kind of let JT, I would say, um, JT kind of runs it. And he, he does a great job, mixes it up well. Yeah. Yeah. He seems like a real, real good dude. Um, he's great.
呃，每个更衣室都不同。嗯，有时你有点让伙计们，你知道，轮流，嗯，但我会说我们的更衣室相当，你知道，我们只是让JT，我会说，嗯，JT算是负责它。而且他，他做得很好，混合得很好。是啊。是啊。他看起来像个真正，真正的好人。嗯，他很棒。
I just do want to know, like, I'm sorry to keep heartbreak on this. I'm trying to picture what your life is when you're not playing baseball. And all I've got is you're running around with kids, but like, that's it. How do you fill the space? I, there's no space. I mean, I, there's no space. I have, I have three kids. So that's like literally 24 seven.
我只是想知道，就像，我很抱歉一直纠结于此。我试图想象当你不在打棒球时你的生活是什么样的。而我所知道的只是你在和孩子们跑来跑去，但就像，就是这样。你怎么填补空间？我，没有空间。我的意思是，我，没有空间。我有，我有三个孩子。所以那就像字面上的24/7。
That's, yeah. That's what I'm doing. I get it. Never been busier just running around with three kiddos. But to your point, I will try to figure something out post, post baseball. I think that will be healthy to figure that out. Um, is there any chance that you could become like a locker room choreographer? Yeah.
那是，是啊。那就是我在做的。我明白了。从来没有比这更忙的了，只是和三个孩子跑来跑去。但说到你的观点，我会尝试在棒球后弄清楚一些事情。我认为弄清楚这一点会很健康。嗯，有没有可能你成为像更衣室编舞师那样的人？是啊。
There you go. If that is a job, I'm, I'm in. I mean, that might be a senior with your headbands on. I mean, you got the headband already. Yeah. Yeah. Maybe you just need leg warmers and you're done. Yeah.
这就对了。如果那是一份工作，我，我加入。我的意思是，那可能是一个戴着头带的老年人。我的意思是，你已经有头带了。是啊。是啊。也许你只需要腿套，你就完成了。是啊。
And my hair's, I kind of like to go a ponytail at times. So tank top ponytail headband, choreographer, no one does a man bun like Clayton. Yeah. He can get a top not going there. Oh, good for you. Yeah, when I retire, I'm going to come back on if y'all guys will have me and nothing but wicking material and a top not, can't wait, you bring up wicking material quite a lot.
而且我的头发，我有时喜欢扎个马背。所以背心、马尾辫、头带、编舞师，没有人像克莱顿那样扎男士发髻。是啊。他可以弄个顶髻。哦，为你高兴。是啊，当我退役时，如果你们愿意让我回来，我将只穿吸湿排汗材料和顶髻，等不及了，你经常提到吸湿排汗材料。
Do you think you have an issue? He's right. He's right. I'm not ashamed. Wicked. You need to wick it. Clayton, I'm going to tell you this. I had a friend, I'd mentioned this to the guys before.
你认为你有什么问题吗？他是对的。他是对的。我不羞耻。吸湿。你需要吸湿。克莱顿，我要告诉你这个。我有一个朋友，我之前向伙计们提到过这个。
I had a friend, this girl, um, I probably, I could say her name, she's not going to care. Rosa Blase and Rosa was married to, oh, shit. I just got served by Rosa Blase. And she was, she was married. She got married to, um, Jim Finn of the Giants, New York Giants. Okay. Yeah. Okay.
我有一个朋友，这个女孩，嗯，我可能，我可以说她的名字，她不会在意的。罗莎·布拉斯，罗莎嫁给了，哦，该死。我刚被罗莎·布拉斯发球了。而且她，她结婚了。她嫁给了，嗯，巨人队的吉姆·芬，纽约巨人队。好的。是啊。好的。
Football player. And so I was at their wedding in Hawaii and she likes to embarrass me and there's tons of football players there. And so she walks me up to this guy. She goes, do you know who this is? I'm like, of course I know. It's Peyton Manning. I know Peyton Manning.
橄榄球运动员。所以我当时在夏威夷参加他们的婚礼，她喜欢让我尴尬，那里有成吨的橄榄球运动员。所以她带我走到这个家伙面前。她说，你知道这是谁吗？我说，我当然知道。是佩顿·曼宁。我知道佩顿·曼宁。
I'm not an idiot. And she goes, I'll give you 10 bucks if you can tell me who he plays for. And I'm like, I have no idea, I have no idea. But here's the point of the story. I know exactly who Clayton Kershaw is and I know exactly who you play for. And you're fantastic. I'm honored. Thank you so much.
我不是白痴。她说，如果你能告诉我他为谁效力，我给你10块钱。我说，我不知道，我不知道。但故事的重点在这里。我完全知道克莱顿·克肖是谁，我也完全知道你为谁效力。而且你太棒了。我很荣幸。非常感谢。
That's amazing. Clayton. Thank you. Thank you very, very, very, very much. Thanks for having me guys. This is a blast. I appreciate it. Thanks for coming, pal.
那太棒了。克莱顿。谢谢。非常，非常，非常，非常感谢。谢谢你们邀请我，伙计们。这太棒了。我很感激。谢谢你的到来，伙计。
See you man. See you soon. See you guys. Bye, buddy. All right. Bye. Oh my God. How cool.
再见伙计。很快再见。再见伙计们。再见，伙计。好吧。再见。哦，天哪。太酷了。
I was so stoked. Can I say that? Am I allowed to say I'm stoked? I'm fairly. Really? Unless you're in a time machine. Okay. Yeah.
我太兴奋了。我可以这么说吗？我被允许说我很兴奋吗？我相当。真的吗？除非你在时间机器里。好的。是啊。
So. I love them. I love them. Clayton Kershaw. I don't know a lot of sports people, but I definitely know who he is. He's a get. He's a major get. Definite get.
所以。我爱他们。我爱他们。克莱顿·克肖。我不认识很多体育界的人，但我绝对知道他是谁。他是一个收获。他是一个重大的收获。绝对的收获。
Probably best pitcher in quite some time, if not forever. And clearly the one of the best baseball names ever, I mean, Clayton Kershaw is too hard syllables right there. Do you think I'm a better right handed pitcher than he is? Yes. You think so? Yeah. Thank you.
可能是相当长一段时间以来最好的投手，如果不是永远的话。而且显然是最好的棒球名字之一，我的意思是，克莱顿·克肖就在那里有两个硬音节。你认为我是一个比他更好的右投手吗？是的。你这么认为吗？是啊。谢谢。
That's a great question. You should ask him that. I know I should have. I like to think of the questions after they've gone. You're the best. But what a guest, Jason. Yeah. Thank you.
那是一个好问题。你应该问他那个。我知道我应该问的。我喜欢在他们走后思考问题。你是最棒的。但真是个好嘉宾，杰森。是啊。谢谢。
And I sincerely mean this. I mentioned this to Jason earlier that I genuinely love when sports people come on because I learned something, I, that's it, I learned something that I didn't know. And I like when you guys quiz me about shit. I think that's because I'm genuinely interested. Well, it's interesting when a guy makes it the way that he has and is so successful at doing that. It's so impressive and fascinating and interesting.
而且我是真诚的。我早些时候向杰森提到过，我真心喜欢体育界的人来，因为我学到了东西，我，就是这样，我学到了我不知道的东西。而且我喜欢你们考我关于狗屎的问题。我想那是因为我真的感兴趣。嗯，当一个人以他那样的方式成功并做到这一点时，这很有趣。这太令人印象深刻、迷人且有趣了。
How did you become the best pitcher in the world? Yeah. Yeah. Anyway, so good. Great. And then we'll talk. We'll talk on the next one. On the flip side.
你是怎么成为世界上最好的投手的？是啊。是啊。无论如何，太好了。太棒了。然后我们会谈。我们会在下一个谈。在另一面。
We'll get you on the flip side. They probably don't even flip sides anymore, but guys, I would be remiss if I could say bae. Bae. Bae. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们会在另一面见到你。他们可能甚至不再翻转面了，但伙计们，如果我能说宝贝，我会失职的。宝贝。宝贝。这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。